salut bienvenue en stockage tels
épisodes 10 et oui ça peut les
anniversaires des couches jetables pour
fêter ça je vais répondre à vos
questions ou est ce que monsieur pomme
régnera sur le monde contre banana man
et protégera t-il son peuple je suis
monsieur pas mais je régnerait sur le
broad après avoir tué banana ma colère
sera terrible peux-tu faire la technique
de kakashi mille ans de souffrance sur
un ton pote avec plaisir techniques
ancestrales de ta joue tout un miracle
mort ne réagit pas et connaît peut-être
la fameuse technique secrète
mon mec tarifs de minecraft comment le
faire décrocher s'il te plaît et de mots
à kutina une solution très simple et
tellement vite tu voles comme superman
[Musique]
as tu déjà à moitié de la pâtée pour
chat si oui à tuer mais ok on va sur un
test culinaire peux-tu pincer les fesses
d'un maximum de personnes en rue alors
dit je te fais un gros pervers mais je
vais tester
[Musique]
tu as un nez oui ah bon tu sais pas dit
je suis moi carlo as-tu déjà eu envie de
tuer quelqu'un oui dit chouette salon
verts ale
que devient ta lampe on ne voit plus
plutôt normal je vais je vais pas vous
dire que je suis pour rien mais à après
on paie toi quand les médecins se plaît
est ce que tu as déjà sous tes parents
si oui comment ont-ils réagi alors oui
j'ai déjà insulté une fois la mer et ça
s'est passé un peu comme ça mais tu nous
faire la même tête que l'écureuil en
mode moments dramatiques
[Musique]
pourquoi tu fais plus un mec pervers
avec les lunettes dans tes vidéos pour
la même raison que la lampe n'est plus
non plus dans mes vidéos
est ce que tu sais danser comme shakira
j'y travaille et c'est le bien pensant
de l'univers tout entier
pourrais-tu nous chanter la chanson de
la reine des neiges libéré délivrés lol
j'ai hâte de voir ça moi aussi j'ai un
enfant
[Applaudissements]
l'usiné je m'en vais
m